.
>> ANY TIME.
JESSE: TODAY IS ANDREW CUOMO'S
LAST DAY OF NEW YORK.
IT'S A SAD DAY, NOT BECAUSE OF
THE WAY HE IS LEAVING BUT
BECAUSE OF ALL THE GREAT WORK HE
HAS LEFT UNDONE.
SOME STAFFERS LEFT UNHARASSED.
SOME GRANDMOTHERS LEFT ALIVE.
FREE TO PLAY ANOTHER ROUND OF
CHECKERS AT THEIR NURSING HOMES.
AND WHILE HE HAS PACKED UP ALL
HIS BELONGINGS AT THE GOVERNOR'S
MANSION HE IS REPORTEDLY LEAVING
SOMETHING BEHIND, HIS DOG.
CAPTAIN.
THE 3-YEAR-OLD SIBERIAN HUSKY
MIX.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS THE LOVE
GOV IS BEGGING MANSION STAFFERS
TO TAKE THE DOG OFF HIS HANDS.
ALTHOUGH HIS SPOKESMAN CLAIMS
IT'S ONLY TEMPORARY.
JOINING ME NOW HOST OF THE MARK
STEYN SHOW.
MARK, HE IS HOMELESS IN THE
GOVERNOR DOESN'T HAVE A HOME?
HE IS OUT ON THE STREETS NOW AND
IS HE ASKING FOR THE MAID TO
HOLD THE DOG?
WHAT'S UP?
>> YEAH.
THIS DOG -- THE STAFFERS DON'T
WANT IT BECAUSE THE DOG
APPARENTLY JUST DRAGS THE
STAFFERS AROUND IN THE BUILDING.
JUST LIKE THE GOVERNOR.
AND CUOMO SAYS THAT THE DOG
URINE UNITED STATES ALL OVER THE
CARPET WHICH IS APPARENTLY JUST
LIKE THE GOVERNOR, TOO.
SO MORE SIMILAR THAN YOU MIGHT
THINK.
BUT, I WAS JUST LISTENING TO THE
PREVIOUS SEGMENT AND, YOU KNOW,
WHAT'S HIS NAME?
DANCING ARE CHUCK SCHUMER, AND
I'M JUST REFLECTING ON HOW
TOTALLY FAKE EVERYTHING IN
POLITICS IS NOW.
I WAS WATCHING FIRE BREATHING
MULLAHS IN KABUL THIS MORNING.
WE LIKE ABOUT THOSE GUYS THEY
SEEM TO BE FOR REAL.
IN AMERICAN POLITICS I'M NOT
ADVOCATING THAT THEY TAKE OVER
HERE BUT COMPARED TO PEOPLE
WHOSE DOG IS A PICKUP WHERE EVEN
YOUR PETS ARE TOTALLY FAKE AND
THIS DOG IS CALLED CAPTAIN.
BIDEN'S DOG IS CALLED MAJOR.
AND I'M WILLING TO BET THAT SOME
DEMOCRAT FOCUS GROUP HAS SAID
YOU SOUND MORE AUTHORITATIVE IF
YOU HAVE AING TWO A MILITARY
RANK.
SO, IF I EVER RUN FOR ANYTHING,
I'M GOING TO HAVE A DOG LIKE
THAT CHIEF OF STAFF MILLIE GUY.
I'M GOING TO HAVE A DOG CALLED
FOUR STAR GENERAL AND HE WON'T
BE ABLE TO CATCH THE CAT BECAUSE
HE WILL BE WEIGHED DOWN BY TOO
MANY MEDALS.
EVERYTHING IS UTTERLY FAKE AND
THE ONLY THING THAT ISN'T FAKE
WAS TRUMP WHO WAS ATTACKED FOR
SAYING HE WASN'T INTERESTED IN
HAVING A WHITE HOUSE DOG BECAUSE
HE WOULDN'T HAVE TIME TO LOOK
AFTER THE DOG.
JESSE: I DON'T SEE TRUMP AS A
DOG GUY STROKE AGO LITTLE PUPPY
ON HIS LAP WATCHING TV OFF THE
WING OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
JUST DON'T SEE IT BUT THAT'S
HIM.
HE WASN'T A FRAUD.
AND IF HE DIDN'T LIKE DOGS, HE
DIDN'T FOCUS GROUP AN ADMIRAL
INTO HIS HOUSE.
SO YOU SEE THESE IMAGES, MARK,
IF I WAS A REPUBLICAN, THIS IS
WHAT I WOULD DO, I WOULD PUT A
LITTLE PICTURE OF CHUCK DANCING
WITH COLBERT LIKE -- AND I WOULD
SPLIT SCREEN IT WITH THE TALIBAN
HOLDING M-4 SURROUNDING AIRPORT
WHILE AMERICANS ARE STRANDED.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
JESSE: PRIORITIES, PEOPLE.
IT'S PRIORITIES.
WE ARE STANDING AMERICANS WHILE
WE ARE DANCING HERE IN THE
STREETS.
>> AND THAT'S FAKE NEWS TOO.
WE ALL KNOW THAT CHUCK AND THAT
LOSER LATE NIGHT GUY WE KNOW
THEY ARE NOT REAL FRIENDS.
WHY ARE THEY PRETENDING TO BE
DANCING PARTNERS?
THAT'S PATHETIC.
THE PROPER RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
SHOW BIZ AND POLITICS IS WHEN
SAM RABURN SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
IN THE $1,950 MADE THE MISTAKE
OF PUTTING HIS HAND ON FRANK
SINATRAS TOAST AND FRANK SAYS
HANDS OFF.
THIS GUY COLBERT IS PATHETIC IN
NOT DOING THE HANDS OFF THE FRED
IN SCHUMER WHO IS A CREEP.
JESSE: I THINK COLBERT NEEDS TO
WORK ON MONOLOGUE GUTFELD JUST
SMOKED HIM LAST WEEK.
GET OFF THE DANCE FLOOR,
COLBERT, GET BACK TO WORK.
YOU ARE FALLING BEHIND.
>> 37 WRITERS AND HE HAS GOT NO
JOKES IN THE MONOLOGUE.
THAT'S FARCE.
JESSE: IMAGINE IF I HAD 37
WRITERS.
WOO.
I NEED TO TALK TO MY AGENT.
>> YOU ARE PRETTY GOOD WITH JUST
THE 26 GUYS.
JESSE: THAT'S RIGHT.
I JUST NEED 26 AND THAT'S ALL I
NEED.
MARK STEYN WHO DOESN'T NEED ANY
WRITERS NOT AT ALL.
IT ALL COMES STR